[Música]
él es mohamed actualmente tiene 25 años
y yo tuve el placer de conocerle hace
dos y aunque él no lo sepa su historia
me afectó más de lo que él cree
él es uno de los 5 millones de
refugiados sirios que salió de su país
tras cinco años de guerra por miedo a
morir en casa o hacerlo militando en el
ejército
en mallorca hay 80 refugiados sirios y
él es uno de ellos su llegada a palma no
fue fácil en 2015 y tras salir de alepo
su ciudad natal
llego en autobús hasta el líbano y allí
estuvo peregrinando semana tras semana
para llegar a turquía donde entró en un
campo de refugiados y allí la policía le
asignó un número para poder cruzar la
frontera
llegado ese momento ahí quedó recluido
durante un año ya que en el momento en
el que él tenía que cruzar esa frontera
se le cerraron las puertas a su turno
fruto de la desesperación y llegado ese
momento mohamed se embarcó en una patera
de goma de no más de seis metros afinado
junto a 35 personas gente mayor niños un
bebé de 6 meses me comentaba que había
muchísimas olas la gente no sabía nadar
iba cayendo al agua en el que me
confesaba que iba a ser el viaje más
terrorífico de su vida
les dejaron a merced del temporal sin
nadie que tripulará esa embarcación 13
horas primero en un río
más tarde 6 horas en mar abierto sin que
pudieran hacer nada y tras haber pagado
más de 600 dólares a la mafia turca
después de este calvario y tras llegar a
atenas el curiosamente se inscribe en un
programa de voluntariado local donde
decide ayudar a la gente más necesitada
de la capital y es allí donde intenta
sobrevivir e ir trabajando en lo que él
puede mientras espera que dentro del
programa de refugiados europeos
aparezca un país que es españa y que vía
madrid llegue a mallorca
a pesar de esta triste historia su
capacidad de superación su pasión su
fuerza de voluntad permitieron que
mohamed terminará ahí sus estudios justo
en medio de una franja terrorista y
teniendo que esquivar de vez en cuando
los tiros de los francotiradores de
camino a la universidad donde allí
desgraciadamente también fue víctima de
un atentado
es el menor de cuatro hermanos y estaba
un día en casa comiendo y me comentaba
que cayó una bomba sobre su tejado y esa
bomba no estrelló y con un sentido del
humor muy particular me dijo víctor esa
bomba me salvó la vida
pero también me di cuenta de que era el
momento de marchar
ay mohamed nos tenemos que dar cuenta
que a día de hoy es delineante habla dos
idiomas con cualificaciones oficiales el
inglés y el castellano además de su
árabe natal está trabajando como técnico
en una empresa de espectáculos de la
isla y este año vamos a seguir formando
en capacitaciones laborales y técnicas
para que crezca como profesional
mientras superamos unas barreras
administrativas burocráticas y
formativas para que él consiga su sueño
que es ser trabajador social porque
quiere vivir ayudando a los demás con
excusa de esta charla de reconocer que
le pregunte a mohamed cuál era uno de
sus mejores talentos él me dijo muy
humildemente que era el de conectar con
las personas he de reconocer que quizá
hay mohamed se equivocaba porque para mí
tiene una lista innumerable de ellos y
sin lugar a dudas el más destacado es el
de la resiliencia
hoy en día uno de mis una de mis labores
es la de dar con el talento en un
contexto donde
frases como yo no valgo tengo miedo a mí
no me van a llamar yo no sirvo pues
juegan un papel desgraciadamente muy
importante en el entorno en el que yo
estoy y les aseguro que nadar a
contracorriente es muy frustrante
trabajo en la fundación se embala uno de
los mayores regalos de mi vida hay que
remontarse a octubre de 2016 cuando
estaba delante de este proyecto
maravilloso que iba a dar un vuelco de
180 grados a mi vida y que sin saberlo
me iba a poner en el lugar que yo tenía
que estar
en la fundación se embala a trabajar con
jóvenes entre 18 y 25 años vulnerables
becando les sus estudios y todo lo que
ellos necesiten para que consigan su
máximo nivel personal físico psicológico
y emocional pero claro que eso no
implica que no nos encontremos jóvenes
que vienen con unas metas inalcanzables
que llevan persiguiendo durante
muchísimo tiempo que buscan ir a lo
fácil bueno y no a lo que realmente
saben o quieren hacer bueno y eso ya ni
les hablo de aquellos que ven el
panorama y las circunstancias y dicen
esto es muy complicado y tirar la toalla
a la primera de cambio por eso desde la
fundación
intentamos que ellos se reflejen en el
espejo de la cruda realidad que aunque
duela un exceso de optimismo de
pesimismo sería igual de malo en ambos
lados y es ahí donde ellos tienen que
saber las capacidades con las que nacen
y con las que están dispuestos a
desarrollar
por eso nosotros tenemos que ser
conscientes de las habilidades que
tenemos que algo parezca muy difícil no
implica que sea imposible ahora claro
supone mucho tiempo mucha dedicación
mucho esfuerzo y eso es lo que no mola
mejorar la técnica en algo dedicarle
horas nada de eso es sencillo pero yo
les aseguro que si ustedes se esfuerzan
seguro que encontrarán lo que realmente
desean
por eso para mí el talento no es un
concepto meramente científico delantero
decía sebastián pero claro es que es
popularmente conocido por todos y es
verdad que genera cierta controversia el
hecho de eso de si es innato o es
adquirido pero les aseguro que nada de
esto tendría sentido si nos olvidáramos
de generarle valor a ese talento por eso
la mejor forma y creo que la más fácil
de entenderlo sería como una mezcla de
cuatro conceptos básicos el primero de
ellos sería el de la habilidad saber
hacer el segundo esa capacidad ese poder
hacer el tercero sería esa actitud el
querer hacer y el cuarto sería y
probablemente uno de los más importantes
hablando de talento sin oportunidad el
de las circunstancias que te dejen hacer
a quien no le parece este detalle este
nivel de perfección en una de mis
esculturas preferidas sin apenas medios
técnicos talento hace más de 500 años
y de el que me dicen es uno de los
nuestros rafa nadal yo le admiro quien
se atrevería a decir que no tiene un
talento portentoso después de todo lo
que ha conseguido
pero miren esta fotografía y tómense
unos segundos para pensar que ven
probablemente vean una foto de unos
jóvenes en la playa quizá la próxima
portada de nuestro calendario de la
fundación pero yo les aseguro que veo
algo más veo 13 historias de talento
maravillosas que están esperando a que
las protagonizan
llegados a este punto nos hemos dado
cuenta de que hemos visto tipos de
talento hemos identificado algunos hemos
visto definiciones pero como descubrimos
ese talento como nos damos cuenta del
talento es complicado verdad ahora
piensen cómo lo hacemos con un joven con
miedo sin recursos sin referentes y con
unos prejuicios adquiridos que hacen que
eso se convierta en una tarea mucho más
complicada
eso implica mucha atención por nuestra
parte pero no significa que no seamos
capaces de verlo
llegados a este punto y tras ver muchas
oportunidades perderse les puedo
asegurar que el único secreto es hacer
de su pasión su proyecto de vida y
demostrarles que tienen que estar
activos porque si uno se queda sentado
la oportunidad no llega
por eso uno crea la oportunidad y muchas
de ellas se están perdiendo por ese
sistema de creencias de estar esperando
a esas oportunidades y les aseguro que
hay muchas formas de encontrar el
talento una de ellas y sin excepción
ninguna muchos de nosotros las hemos
hecho quien no ha querido parecerse a su
deportista preferido es superar a su
maestro en el colegio o parecerse a sus
padres pues esa imitación de la que les
hablo llega un punto en el que aparece
la comparación y smata esa
capacidad de imitación
por eso ellos tienen que saber qué hacer
con sus circunstancias
llegados a este punto ellos crean esa
oportunidad y empiezan a desarrollar
unas habilidades que hasta la fecha
desconocían
son grandes pequeñas historias hoy son
ellos pero mañana podemos ser nosotros
no somos tan diferentes
yo personalmente tuve una infancia
agridulce por una de las partes parece
ser que el ser padre no está hecho para
todo el mundo tuve momentos complicados
de cierta soledad y de demasiada auto
conversación conmigo mismo probablemente
más de las que yo hubiera querido para
un niño de no más de 12 años es ahí
donde te das cuenta que esas
experiencias lo único que hacen es que
crezcas que te entiendas que te escuchen
y que establezcas prioridades y sin duda
alguna esas vivencias lo único que hacen
es darte cuenta de que todas esas
experiencias tienen un lado positivo y
que de una manera o de otra abren una
parte poco transitada de tu cerebro y es
ahí donde eres capaz de descubrir esas
capacidades que te hacen mejor persona y
te ayudan a crecer pero llegó un momento
donde los sabios consejos de mi madre
los valores la moralidad el amor y la
pasión con las que ella me educó me
abrieron los ojos me enseñaron que esas
experiencias esas causas y esas
consecuencias eran las responsables de
que a día de hoy pues yo pueda estar
desarrollando unos talentos que
desconocía y que es real y que de
repente
y aparecen no pero porque les cuento
todo esto pues porque debido a esas
experiencias de maduración forzada se
fueron desarrollando el entusiasmo el
sentido del humor la empatía la
solidaridad talentos que a día de hoy yo
puedo seguir trabajando y puedo
compartir con la gente con la que
trabajo
créanme que el desarrollo del talento
influye mucho más de lo que ustedes
creen en la superación de experiencias
traumáticas como las de ellos y que si
cuidamos un poquito más como decimos las
cosas que realmente que decimos en sí el
talento brota solo por eso qué les
parece si de una vez por todas luchamos
contra el miedo la frustración la
incertidumbre y la consiguiente pérdida
de talentos en nuestros jóvenes
hoy me ha tocado a mí pero les aseguro
que cualquiera de ustedes podría estar
aquí en mi lugar al principio de esta
ponencia me han presentado y la verdad
que a excepción de mis amigos y mi
familia nadie me conozca pero me siento
muy orgulloso de estar aquí comunicando
con ustedes y transmitiéndoles todo lo
que hago y lo que me queda por hacer sin
embargo es momento de reflexionar de
marcará la diferencia de luchar contra
la escasez de talento cuando con un
nivel de conocimiento altísimo tenemos
índices bajísimos de selección de
talento las empresas
y de que una vez por todas se nos dé el
mismo talento en todos los sectores ya
que si en sí y por sí misma la búsqueda
del talento es un reto imagínense que
hacerlo en jóvenes en riesgo de
exclusión social lo único que hace es
que el descubrimiento de sus altas
capacidades
una vez que brillen lo hagan con más
fuerza
una vez estaba con un joven y atrás que
es todo lo que él había conseguido y
todo por todo lo que le había pasado le
pregunté oye y tú qué es lo que no sabes
hacer él me miró y me dijo víctor lo que
todavía no me he propuesto aprender ese
joven era mohamed
[Aplausos]
y